if you enjoyed haze like studios split
screen bathtub award winning game a way
out then the upcoming coop action
adventure it takes two will be right up
your alley
[Music]
clear on the culture online these two
player game features general bending
challenges and level unique puzzles that
will set you and your friend on an
engaging and interactive fantastical
journey the gameplay demo that we got
our hands on have us play as cody and
may a couple on the verge of divorce who
are mysteriously turned into dolls by
their daughter roles though the gameplay
revolves around the couple the story
also centers around rosa's struggle to
get their parents back together
as people transformed into dolls stuck
in a miniature world a magical book that
rose was trying to get her father to
read appears as dr hakeem players will
see him throughout the game as he
happily sets us through an involuntary
and perilous journey to help us get to
roles
how the game sets itself apart is the
way to merge narrative and gameplay as
you venture through the game you will
slowly start to see the couple work
through their marriage facing challenges
that are actually metaphorical
representations of their dispute
throughout each level we came across
several unique tools that both players
have to use to progress further into the
game cody and may both have their own
gameplay that they have to work with so
it's never the same
each level design that we experience
were unique and as promised by the
developers a genre on its own
collectibles are pretty much
non-existent in this game so don't worry
about missing trophies and fully delve
into the gameplay experience as it takes
to emphasizes heavily on its interactive
environment mini games are scattered
throughout the game for players to have
a little bit of healthy competition with
each other nothing like a little bit of
whack-a-mole to spice up the
competitiveness with your friend with
easy to understand game mechanics and
simple controls it takes two is an
uncomplicated game with enduring
cinematics that captures both the
essence of good gameplay experience and
storyline over the course of the demo we
did die several times
but it seems like there are no complete
game overs
players have a health bar to watch out
for but can respond as much as they want
difficulty of each stage is tied to
their own style of gameplay and doesn't
work like other multiplayers such as
overcooked increasing complexity and
difficulty as players progress
unfortunately we only had the chance to
play up to chapter 2 but it was enough
for us to experience what the developers
from haze like studios had to offer it
takes two takes a captivating and
heartfelt narrative surrounding cody and
may while giving us an insight from the
point of view of rose through the demo
we felt like we were part of the world
as the environment and story comes to
life with amazing voice acting and
screenplay of the characters
so expect a whole lot of fun challenging
gameplays and powerful narratives that
can keep you on the edge of your seats
another good news is with a friend pass
only one friend has to buy a copy of the
game to play together with that we are
looking forward to the official release
of the game and we cannot wait to play
more and fully explore the story and
find out if cody and may are stuck
forever as goals
you